donc poursuit cette analyse d'elle de
l'allocution présidentielle avec arnaud
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire
bonsoir arnaud benedetti merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france qu'en
avez vous retenu de cette allocution
présidentielle le président a dit nous
n'avons pas à rougir de notre bilan
qu'en pensez vous at il raison les côtés
de kevin allocution bilan qui a visé a
finalement construire un récit de la
victoire de l'état dans cette crise du
condamné russe c'était en tout cas le
sens premier de tout du premier tiers de
l'intervention du président de la
république
elle est ensuite c'était disons une
allocution programme où le président la
république s'est efforcé de tracer les
grandes lignes de ce que devrait être à
ses yeux le monde d'après en réalité
finalement la locution était contrainte
par le timing parce que sur la question
de la communication crise le premier
ministre avait déjà annoncé l'essentiel
au fur et à mesure de l'ensemble de ces
interventions et ensuite il était encore
trop tôt en raison d'un cycle politique
qui n'est pas achevée avec les
municipales pour faire des annonces
politiques beaucoup plus concrète donc
il s'agit plutôt d'une d'une
intervention intermédiaire que le
président de la république a voulu faire
en rappelant que à ses yeux l'état
n'avait pas à rougir de la façon dont il
avait géré cette situation en alençon 1
déconfinement un peu plus rapide qu'il
ne l'était envisagée donc c'est un moyen
pour le président de la république de
d'annoncer quelques bonnes nouvelles
notamment au quartier aux restaurateurs
en région parisienne mais sur le fond il
n'y avait pas disons un exercice qui se
traduisait beaucoup de nouveautés dans
son dans son expression beaucoup
d'intentions également
non pas forcément vous le disiez
d'annoncés concrètes selon vous emmanuel
macron at il tiré les leçons de la crise
à travers ses mots c'est ce qui leur
promet en tout cas il ya deux éléments
qui sont en tout cas important dans son
discours d'abord un élément qui est un
élément sur le plan j'allais dire du
contenu politique
il a beaucoup insisté mais il l'avait
déjà fait auparavant sur la question de
l'indépendance
il a parlé d'une économie qui devait
être indépendant de solidaires
écologistes ce qui permet à la fois de
parler d'un côté aux souverainistes
d'un côté à dison la la la la gauche de
sa majorité qui est plus préoccupé par
le social et à travers l'évocation de
l'écologie deux par les eaux aux
écologistes
ça c'est un premier point le deuxième
point c'est que il a voulu insister sur
la méthode également c'est que il y
aurait une reconstruction il employé
pour la première fois je crois le terme
de reconstruction mais que cette
reconstruction
elle se ferait avec l'ensemble des corps
intermédiaires mais aussi en sollicitant
le président de l'assemblée nationale le
président du sénat le président du
conseil économique et social et donc il
a parlé à ce moment là en effet de la
nécessité de se réinventer qu'il
s'appliquait à lui même comme s'il
faisait entre l'auto critique de la
méthode qu'il avait utilisé ces trois
dernières années
voilà à peu près sur le fond ce qu'il
faut en mon sens se retenir en matière
de changement de 2,2 en tout cas tu
annonces de changement de comportement
du président de la république vous
l'avez trouvé humainement a peut-être
plus humbles dans son discours ce soir
que les fois précédentes il y avait
moins d'emphase il y avait plus de
sobriété c'était un discours qui était
archi textures et autour de trois
principaux éléments d'abord un bilan de
ce qui s'était passé en rappelant que
l'état malgré les difficultés avaient
été assez eu encore une fois à la
hauteur
de la tâche un deuxième élément qui
consistait à bâtir un certain nombre de
lignes d'avenir pour les politiques
qu'il faudrait mettre en place pour
répondre aux conséquences économiques et
sociales de la crise et un troisième
temps qui lui était allé dire plus
conjoncturelle et qui est peut-être la
partie la plus intéressante finalement
de son intervention c'est la réponse à
l'enjeu des violences policières et des
mobilisations anti raciste qui sont
apparus depuis
dixième du jour là aussi il était très
attendu et effectivement sur ces
manifestations contre le racisme et ses
policiers qui manifestent de leur côté
parce qu'ils se disent pas raciste dans
leur globalité
là c'est aussi la politique du en même
temps qu'à employer le président ce sera
je dirais que c'est certainement le
sujet où il a été le plus épineux prix
expliciter le moins ambiguë
vraisemblablement il a apporté quand
même un soutien me semble-t-il sans
faille aux forces de police au moment où
ces dernières paraît se douter de leur
ministre de l'intérieur et surtout il a
rappelé une conception de la république
qui est une conception qui s'opposent à
une certaine forme de communautarisme
voire d'un dizaine isme qui s'exprime
dans les mobilisations contre les
policiers en ce moment donc il a pris
plutôt là pour le coup disons une une
position qui est assez explicite et qui
parle certainement une partie de
l'opinion qui est à la fois très attaché
à la question de l'autorité à travers la
police est très agacé aussi à une
certaine conception de la république qui
est une conception universaliste loin de
tout l'est de tous les identitarisme et
il a insisté aussi sur le fait qu'il ne
fallait pas déboulonner des statuts il
n'y aura pas deux il n'y a pas de
repentance de sa part certainement pas
c'est encore une fois le point de sot
une expression qui que ce soit dans le
le mois de prise à toute forme
d'ambiguïté
il a voulu rappeler qu'il assume et en
l'occurrence l'histoire de france à la
fois dans toute sa complexité et dans
toute sa diversité
donc là il parle très clairement à
l'ailé droite de sa majorité est aussi
une partie de la gauche
très attaché à ce modèle républicain il
c'est d'une certaine manière pour le
coup encore plus éloigné de la gauche
sociétale qui ne l'avait fait jusqu'à
maintenant
à travers cette intervention encore une
fois qui vraisemblablement et dans la
partie de son discours l'élément le plus
j'allais dire le plus affirmé le plus à
ce permis est peut-être le plus novateur
est-ce que selon vous on assiste ce soir
au début au lancement en tout cas d'un
nouvel élan pour ce mandat il reste 2
ans ou président pour diriger la france
est ce qu'il y aura un changement de
méthode on sait qu'en juillet a priori
il devrait annoncer un remaniement il y
aura une nouvelle équipe pour appliquer
en tout cas les grandes lignes dites ce
soir par le président alors le
changement méthode dans la rhétorique
présidentielle c'est pas et figures tout
à fait nouvelle souvenez vous après la
crise des gilets jaunes et même
lorsqu'il a annoncé l'acte 2 200 de son
gouvernement
il avait là aussi parlé de changement de
méthode donc on peut pas aujourd'hui
considéré que cette cette formulation de
changement de méthode constitue un vrai
un vrai tournant dans la façon dont le
président de la république souhaite
expliquer son action
aujourd'hui la difficulté pour emmanuel
vacances c'est qu'il est confronté à
moins de deux ans de la fin de son
mandat à une crise qui est inédite et
qui vient profondément bousculé le récit
j'allais dire de son mandat et surtout
le logiciel politique qui était le sien
donc il va falloir qui colmate des vrais
c'est ça le plus difficile aujourd'hui
pour ce qui le concerne et il ya une
nécessité surtout c'est de pouvoir
disposer d'une majorité qui puisse être
une majorité stable
or le problème c'est que on l'a vu
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines sa
majorité au parlement a commencé à se
diviser avec notamment la création de
deux nouveaux groupes parlementaires ce
qui fait que la république à marche ne
dispose plus d'une majorité absolue sur
le plan arithmétique à l'assemblée
nationale et ce qui n'est pas bien
évidemment sont posé un certain nombre
de difficultés
quant au calendrier politique qui va
être le sien c'est-à-dire de pouvoir à
la fois permettre à l'économie de
redémarrer dans des conditions qui
soient le moins dramatique possible
continue du choc que la société
française doit absorber et surtout
d'aborder une fin de mandat qui est une
femme en a qu'un qui reste profondément
encore plombée par une défiance dans
l'opinion publique vis-à-vis du
président de la république qui est pas
seulement conjoncturelle mais qui est
profondément structurelles et
structurantes
une dernière question arnaud benedetti
très court c'est un discours qui visait
aussi à rassurer les français en cette
période de crise sanitaire et là il a
réussi
difficile de le dire je pense que le
lave les la véritable étape ça sera le
discours du début juillet c'est à dire
après les élections municipales au
moment du conseil une des chefs d'état
et de gouvernement européens où là on
aura vraisemblablement un président de
la république il livrera la ligne
politique et les hommes et les femmes
qui devront mettre en place cette ligne
politique
c'est à ce moment là qu'on peut mesurer
si le président est en mesure de créer
un choc psychologique dans l'opinion
mais malgré le moment merci beaucoup
arnaud benedetti d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur arte france